in the past few Decades of Television it
wouldn't be very difficult to find a
show that didn't get the ending you
thought it deserved for many of you in
this moment the one you unfortunately
might think of first is Attack on
[Music]
Titan this is your spoiler warning for
the entire show of
course now when I come across an ending
that is as strongly divisive as Attack
on Titans is I try to separate myself s
and think what happened not what went
wrong or what should have been done but
simply what happened because for every
person that dislikes a controversial
ending to a show there's almost always
another person who enjoys it some people
enjoy things that others don't it's as
simple as that some people will have
enjoyed seeing the strong feelings Aaron
still had for micasa at the end despite
his behavior and mannerisms and some
won't some some will like that not
everything was fixed by Aaron at the
very end of the show that there wasn't
Eternal peace but some would have wanted
everything to be right and peaceful
neither side is really wrong for feeling
the way they do so I try to maintain a
balance between the two because well
that's my job
here after reading attack on 's ending
well over 2 years ago and now watching
it I couldn't help but try to analyze
and explain just how it happens how such
beloved incredible shows so often build
up to a finale that ends up being so
controversial and before we get any
deeper I want to preface before everyone
starts commenting I like the ending I've
liked it ever since I read it 2 and 1/2
years ago with my old video from back
then as proof and I still like it now I
think some things went extremely well
some things went pretty poorly and some
things went fine
I know there are parts that were not
executed well trust me I know you don't
have to tell me and I'm not necessarily
excusing those aspects of the episode
I'm acknowledging them here and giving
my insight into more context of the
journey up until this point and how our
world itself has affected our opinion of
it because it's about more than just
this single ending chapter ending
episode it's 11 and 1/2 years of work
and buildup and I've thought about this
case for a long time now as I said and
it led me on a long path of
self-reflection on not only what I enjoy
but what the community at large finds
satisfying in an ending the first step
of this lengthy investigation quite
inevitably led me to look at the broader
scope of things the context or maybe a
better word for my explanation here is
the
[Music]
zeitgeist
let me explain this briefly before
circling back to attack on Titan the
word Zeitgeist means the spirit of the
time it is the trends and thoughts and
feelings within a certain era and it is
often reflected through media the way
characters act what they say how the
story is portrayed it all when looked at
through the right lens has some sort of
Reflections and mirroring in society in
whatever period of time that the story
came out in to give a few examples let's
look at 12 Angry Men a classic American
film from the 20th century in this movie
these strong opinions and dialogue among
the characters about the race and
upbringing of the defendant whose guilt
they're trying to decide on is famous
for reflecting the ongoing divisiveness
of segregation in America at the time of
the movie in the late
50s likewise let's bring it back to
anime look at how the Acura slide is
recreated across all kinds of media
throughout history it's demonstrative of
the era we now live in and How Deeply
ingrained in society anime and Japanese
influences have become over the past 50
or so years the Zeitgeist is the
embodiment of society's ever shifting
culture if you
will now in that same vein we as Western
TV show Watchers have come to be
disappointed time and time again with
the endings of TV shows over the past
few
decades truthfully at this point it is
sadly just about as common to come
across a popular TV show where the
ending disappoints rather than
delivers the last season most notably of
many modern shows completely collapse
ranging from dramas like lost and Dexter
to sitcoms like How I Met Your Mother
and the office though the latter still
managed to pull together a pretty good
ending and that is not to mention what
of course everyone was thinking of here
the king of monsters himself game of of
Thrones it has built us up over decades
to focus more and more as a society on
the endings because they are so hard to
perfectly land and because we are so
often disappointed by them they
frequently become the utmost focus in
determining a Show's worth no matter
what came before it oh how quickly did
Game of Thrones fall from society's
Graces after becoming such a central
part of the modern Zeitgeist coining
terms that were so well known like King
in the north Mother of Dragons the Red
Wedding being hailed as easily one of
the most beloved and influential pieces
of media in the 2010s it is now almost
exclusively remembered and memorialized
as a good series ruined by a poorly made
ending heavy emphasis on the poorly made
ending having a quote unquote Game of
Thrones ending is an ingrained piece of
the modern era Zeitgeist a
representation of our Collective sadness
over frequently witnessing Bad Endings
to some of the best TV shows ever and
its permeation into our very perspective
of all TV media in the aftermath still
lasts to this
day and Attack on Titan got really big
like the number one show in America when
it was airing
big Amplified by the Boost in mainstream
popularity that anime got over the
course of the pandemic Attack on Titan
built up slowly but surely to an epic
finale one that inevitably was bound to
face the scrutiny and criticism of
mainstream audiences who have grown to
want the world from a Show's ending
there are expectations in place now
Society has come to expect something
conditioned to dislike seeing endings
fail so badly that we've grown to Crave
only the best of
endings this
psychologically practically sets us up
for
disappointment John Green said it
extremely well it occurred to me that
the voracious ambition of humans is
never sated by dreams coming true
because there is always the thought that
everything might be done better and
again essentially we will never be
satisfied because we always want more
from
it in all truths it is fair to do this
but people expect the perfect ending an
ending that would resolve all endings
tie up all loose ends and please oh God
just don't pull a Game of
Thrones and the finale arrived in the
attack on Titan manga first 2 and 1/2
years ago and well people immediately
started comparing it to Game of Thrones
in terms of its scale of disaster which
I don't necessarily agree with at all
people wanted to rewrite it or have this
character have this ending or have this
storyline end this way there is simply
no way to satisfy everyone's
expectations that's the
truth let's bring it to a more specific
context within Attack on Titan to one of
the most divisive issues with the ending
Aaron's character Arc some fans love
Aaron Post Time Skip and wanted to see
that Aaron had everything planned his
outer appearance of Silence brooding and
deceit reflected his inner determination
to do what he believed needed to be done
to free his people they wanted to
believe that having seen the past
present and future he had put the puzzle
pieces together and knew exactly what he
had to do
now but now let's look at the other fans
whose faith lies with pre- time skip
Aaron who believe that this is all a
facade who acknowledge that Aaron's
shift in character after the time skip
is not a reflection of true character
development but think that this is a
sign that he has ironically lost his
Free Will and pursuit of freeing his
people that perhaps the younger
headstrong and Brash Aaron that we knew
pre-time skip never left but is instead
being pulled into the tide by the
overwhelming power of the attack Titan
to carry out a future and fate that he
can see but cannot
control I think both sides are equally
valid
arguments in fact I don't think that
either one is completely wrong and that
both actually have some qualities that
are true and I think the ending shows
that Aaron did have the determination
needed to free his people and the
mindset to carry out the rumbling but at
the same time he was still a slave to
yamir's powers and the future that he
witnessed he was still a young child
it's something you can see in his
Outburst to Armen about
Mikasa but of course there was still
that darker side of him as well but
because both sides of interpretation are
quite radically different the people who
expected Aaron to turn out exactly how
they think he should be on their side of
the argument are disappointed to see
that he might fall a little bit on the
other side
too there's a quote I quite like by
Donald Miller where he says when you
stop expecting people to be perfect you
can like them for who they
[Music]
are look none of us truly understood
Aaron after the time skip his intentions
were muddy at best because we didn't
know the range of his powers the extent
of his master plan because isama never
fully told us and throwing it all at the
end
yeah it could have been done better by
him this isn't all on the fans it's a
shared effort with isama I'm not going
to say he's a saint and that everything
was done right because again it
wasn't but we never knew 100% Who Aron
was it was a primordial soup of crafted
theories that gave life to our vision of
Aaron and this led to people having such
divisive and opinionated views on him
people built their own theories ideas in
their heads because there was so little
to form any kind of agreed consensus
around and when you finally reveal who
he is at the very end of the story it's
setting up a lot of those people on
either side for
disappointment because they wanted
something something more instead of just
accepting what
[Music]
is and look no matter what can be said
about the ending isama does deserve
credit where it's due this road to make
a manga is not an easy one manga series
are notoriously taxing to write both
physically and mentally even if we were
to disregard the lack of sleep and
carpal tunnel and spinal injury inducing
toll that constantly drawing and writing
entails you have to look at what
creating a monthly manga like Attack on
Titan really means think about this if
you're a normal author you have an
initial deadline for your book in its
entirety before you hand it over to the
editors and Publishing
Company each chapter varies in
difficulty and pressure to write some
have important moments some don't and so
you can adjust your pace as much as you
need to until you inevitably hit the
doct if you really needed to you could
spend half a year on the first 90% of
the book and spend the last half of the
Year writing the last 10% making sure to
tie up every loose end carefully and
finish it in style of course I'm not
saying this has how it goes but they
have the ability to
choose that's not to mention that if
it's a series spanning multiple books
you have who knows how long between
sequels to plan out your next move I
mean look George RR Martin hasn't
published a new book in The Game of
Thrones series in over 12 years for
reference Attack on Titan and its 139
chapters were all written and published
in only 11
[Music]
the manga industry is very very
different from what we see as normal
writing imagine you're writing a book
but you must draw edit revise and
publish every single chapter every
single month and every month after you
have to release it your work is at the
world's Mercy left to their critiques
and opinions you see what they say how
they view it and you must continue
writing
afterwards writing a manga is not a
solitary journey by any means for the
author it is completed in slow steady
iterations and that builds
pressure don't you think that isama
wanted a take back at any point don't
you think that any manga author thought
oh I could have written that better or
that chapter could have been slightly
better but they didn't have a choice
once you make a chapter There's No Going
Back
many authors know the ending they want
to create from the very start but who's
to say that the Publishing Company won't
make you change things along the way or
that a Fan's critiques of one chapter
won't influence how your next chapter
looks it's impossible to plan every step
of a manga from the start so even if you
know the ending from the very beginning
you don't know all the story lines
you're going to have to wrap up by that
ending that's a daunting task when every
move you make is subject to the world's
views and
Scorn look Attack on Titan got the
ending that it did isama had the chance
to rewrite things for the last episode
but for the most part he didn't because
this is the ending and for a moment I
think we just have to step back and
instead of imposing our own expectations
to desires and ideas onto this final
chapter of an incredible Saga
acknowledge that this is how the
character stories ended it's just like
Attack on Titans themes ironically
things don't always end happy some
things will be good a lot of things
won't but you have to push on in life
regardless otherwise we'll just continue
feeding into our own hatred of TV show
endings until there's nothing left to do
but dread them knowing that they will
never be as good as we want them to be
so
just enjoy the moment because none of
our lives would be the same without
Attack on Titan thank you
[Music]
isama no one's perfect but you brought
something amazing to the
world I will now sign off on what is
most likely my very last video on Attack
on Titan that's
that's pretty crazy to
say as always this has been the anime
culture corner I hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like And subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character
analyses